good morning everyone it is alex from
ozzy here from
gym launch prestige allen and the many
other companies that we have in our
portfolio
they did 110 million dollars in sales
and i am going to tell you how we did
that
um and i have nothing to sell you so um
without further ado the purpose of this
video is to show you the six ways to
increase lifetime value
all right and i'm going to show you my
favorite one at the end of this that i
think is the most powerful
of the six all right and so first thing
we have to do is define lifetime value
all right so there's two ways to grow
business
from a fundamental standpoint number one
is you get more customers number two you
make those customers worth more
that's it that's it
so it would behoove us as business
owners who are trying to make more and
grow our businesses that we should know
all of the different ways to a get more
customers and b make them worth more
all right now when i say make them worth
more lifetime value is a very
loosely defined term you can look on the
internet there's lots of different
definitions for it
and what i'm going to do is redefine
this as lifetime gross profit
all right so lt gp which is what i care
about
all right because for example if i'm
selling a meal for ten dollars
and i make uh it cost me nine dollars to
deliver the meal
i mean i make a dollar so if i sell
someone
and it cost me five dollars to get
somebody to buy a ten dollar meal is
that a good
business proposition for me well you're
making ten dollars it costs you five
you're getting two to one
well my cost of delivering it's nine out
of the ten dollars which means i spend
five dollars to make one dollar
of gross profit all right and so that is
why it's gp
all right that's why i don't like
lifetime values in a more it's a very
amorphous term
and so what we're looking for is how
much juice how much gross profit is
there
over the lifetime of the customer for us
all right
now that's not net profit net profits
after you've paid all of your
all the other expenses your rent your
payroll all the other things um
but this is just the gross margin that
comes in if it costs you two dollars to
buy a thing and you sell it for six
then the gross margin is four now you
still got to pay you know your warehouse
and whatever other things you have going
on
now hopefully you understand lifetime
gross profit so i can get into the
goodies
all right so there's six ways to
increase ltv
the first one is increase the price
sounds crazy but believe it or not price
in and of itself
is something that can actually draw
alert to your your products you think if
a chanel purse sold for 20
people would think they're as cool no
price in and of itself can create alert
around a product it can
put you in another category so much so
that people say this is so much more
expensive
there must be something different about
this i'm going to look at this more
closely right
number two is that you can decrease the
cost
all right so if i can find a cheaper way
to do the thing i can invest in
technology invest in processes i invest
in outsourcing
all these different ways that i can
deliver the same thing for less
i increase my gross profit so if i had
that meal thing that i was talking about
earlier and it cost me nine dollars to
make the meal but i found this new
automated robotic process that allows me
to do the meals for two dollars
that very much increases the lifetime
gross profit
of my of my bit of my of my products and
my business
but i didn't change anything besides
decreasing the cost
all right uh the next one
is to increase purchase frequency all
right so what this is
is getting people to buy again and again
and again if i can get someone to come
to my restaurant today and tomorrow and
then continue to come forever
then that's going to be a much more
valuable client right and so that
increases if i can get all of my clients
to come in additional one time
right that would increase my lifetime
gross profit per customer across my
entire business
all right so if you're tracking with me
number one you can increase the price
number two you can decrease how much it
costs you to fulfill the thing
right number three you can get people to
buy more times
all right and then four five and six are
slightly related but different
all right the first is that you can
upsell people all right
now upsells very important here
i'm going to define this for you is
selling
the same thing but a more valuable
version so if you upgrade
right from uh from a honda to a lexus
then you're getting
upsold right important and i think it's
important to define these terms because
they are different types of sales and if
you can be more nuanced in how you think
you will think better all right
especially when it comes to your
business so the next so that's
that's buying so i'll give you a a food
example so if i go from
a you know 20 ounce soda to a 32 on soda
that is an upsell
it's more of the same it's either better
of the same or more of the same but
either way
it's the same category of stuff um
i'm just i'm just buying a bigger better
version of it all right
the next is a cross sell all right
across cell is an adjacent
need that i am solving all right so in
the burger
or sorry in the in the coke example if i
sell a burger with the coke
then that is a cross cell right so
upsell is small coke to big coke
or you know uh normal lemonade to
to organic whatever lemonade you know
espresso
sun-kissed lemonade or whatever it is
right that's an upsell
a cross that would be uh what do you
want with that lemon do you want a
sandwich with that lemonade
uh what do you want with that soda you
want a burger with that soda do you want
fries with that soda
right that is a cross-sell all right
that's a cross-sell so you're selling an
additional thing this is usually the
next
natural need that the person is going to
have as a result of their first
purchasing decision
oftentimes these cross sales are
actually where the majority of the
profit happens
so sometimes there are strategies and
businesses that are called loss leaders
everyone needs this one thing
but the next thing they need is gonna be
the thing that has all the margin and if
you know your numbers
you can build a model around that very
successfully all right
and then finally this is one that's
overlooked
is down cells right so a lot of
businesses that i'll talk to or that
consult with
they don't have any down cells and so
that means that there's all this traffic
that's coming to their site or getting
on the sales calls with them
but those those people have needs too
and it might not fit in your primary
uh category this is especially true if
you sell a higher a higher level service
or a more expensive service
um a lot of times you're still paying
for this traffic right this traffic
these eyeballs
are still yours and i like to think of
this as one person's trash is another
person's treasure there's
always a business that can do something
with uh some of the
kind of the sawdust the excess capacity
that we have that exists within our
business
right and so down cells you can either
down sell to someone else's product
and get affiliate commissions get
referral partner commissions for for
for sending business their way or right
and i like that a lot because you're you
have a nice relationship with another
business you think they have a good
product they specialize in serving that
type of customer
um and you both benefit you make money
they get free customers everybody wins
the customer gets solved
right and they're going to thank you for
making the introduction as long as you
have good partners which you obviously
should
the other way to do this is to have
lesser
you know lesser lesser cost of
fulfillment
but it's solving the same need so um
i'm trying to think an example of this
so yeah if you had like a done for you
service of some
type right and the person couldn't
afford your full suite of services you
could down sell
a kind of a done with you or do it
yourself version of that
right and so making those products
taking the one-time investment
of making that product or making that
you know done with you version of your
of your primary done for you service or
whatever it is
a lot of times can serve as a really
good downsell right if someone walks
into a facility for personal training
and they can't afford personal training
obviously there's groups and things like
that they could do that would be a
natural downside
but maybe they want to stay at home and
you give them an at-home version right
so there's all these different ways
you can you can slice and dice this but
fundamentally
if we have people that were normally not
giving us money because they would say
no
but now we're able to monetize them in
some way we have now
made more money per customer all right
and it's really per
per person who walks into our business
all right so
six ways to increase lifetime value of a
customer lifetime gross profit
one is you can increase the price and
automatically you make more money
number two is you're gonna decrease how
much it costs you to fulfill the thing
that you're promising
number three is you can increase
purchase frequency or getting the amount
of time someone buys from you get them
to buy more
right over time number four is
upselling them that means having
structured upsells where they can get
buy more of the same stuff or better
versions of the same stuff
all right cross-sells is selling the
next adjacent needs you have to think
yourself someone buys my service what's
the next thing they're normally going to
need
i'm going to sell them that too right
and it also makes their life easier
because they can get all their stuff
from one place
makes you more money everyone wins and
then finally what can i do with the
sawdust what are all these people who
are coming into my business who can't
necessarily afford my main thing and how
can i how can i create something that's
still going to solve their need
but doesn't cost me that much so i can
still make a good a good margin on this
stuff or
how can i refer the business out to
someone else and still get a kickback
from it
and so those are the six ways to
increase lifetime
gross profit now i told you the
beginning i was gonna tell you the thing
that i think is the most powerful
it's this guy understanding price
pricing is one of the most underutilized
levers in the entirety of business
most people figure out their pricing by
looking at the marketplace taking
average saying i guess i'll charge that
the secret that they don't know is that
everyone else is broke
think about it everyone else is broke
and especially if you're entering the
small business ownership the reason that
small businesses are small is because
they think like small business owners
not big business owners
that's why they stay that's why they
stay small and so
don't model small businesses look at the
pricing models of big businesses now
strong word of caution here there are
market penetration strategies that
businesses can do because they have
funding and things like that but if you
look at mature businesses businesses
that have gone through the rapid growth
phase and then
have sustained look at the pricing model
they have because what the model that
they had
they have already tested and obviously
has produced sufficient margins
that they are able to continue to grow
their company all right
and so don't look at the small guys
don't look at the person who's out of
shape and try and model what they're
doing
right that's a problem fitness is a
horrible example because people have
great genetics or bad genetics in
any ways but point is don't look for
dentists who have bad teeth right
look for somebody who's got nice teeth
and i'm sure there's genetics there too
these are horrible examples but
hopefully you get the point
all right is that pricing is the most
important lever and i'll give you one
quick example on this
if something cost me ten dollars to
fulfill right and i charge twenty
dollars for it
cool i'm making you know fifty percent
gross margin
but if i say you know what i'm going to
charge 50 for this thing or you know
what
we'll say 30. so i go from 20 to 30
right i just doubled the lifetime gross
profit of my business
doubled right there are very few of
these other mechanisms that can
double or triple or quadruple the
lifetime gross profit
of your business or per client rather
than
price all right which is also why it's
one of the ones that people have the
biggest limiting beliefs around
and the ones that most people struggle
to increase and the good thing is if
lots of people struggle to do it
it means there's plenty of opportunity
for all of us all right so
six ways to increase lifetime gross
profit there's two ways to grow business
one of them gets is getting more
customers the other one
is increasing how much those customers
are worth and here are six strategies
that you can think about within your
business
of how you can apply these things um to
your
client journey so that you can make
those clients worth more without
doing any extra work lots of love keep
being awesome catch you guys soon bye